un homme placé en détention provisoire
se laisse mourir au centre pénitentiaire
de ducos
c'est ce que déclare les surfeurs
affiliés au syndicat force ouvrière dans
ce communiqué adressé ce matin à notre
rédaction il souhaite éviter un
troisième drame après le suicide de
détenus
au mois d'octobre dernier nous avons
actuellement un détenu incarcéré depuis
le mois d'août dans une procédure
criminelle très lourde et qui depuis
trois semaines ne refuse de se nourrir
ne dialogue pas et se trouve dans un
état psychologique physique délabrée
mais on pourrait dire pratiquement à
l'état d'animal
selon l'administration pénitentiaire que
nous avons contacté le détenu âgé de 28
ans s'offrirait bien avant son
incarcération de troubles du
comportement
il y aura tout de même bénéficié d'un
placement à l'isolément comme il est
prévu à pareille circonstance de leur
côté les surveillants de force ouvrière
parle de situations d'urgence il
souhaite que détenus soient transférés
le plus rapidement que possible en
france
aujourd'hui le cpdh ducos si près de 40%
de détenus ayant des profils
psychiatrique inadapté pour
l'établissement
ces détenus n'ont rien à faire en milieu
carcéral ces détenus méritent des soins
en milieu hospitalier
la prison n'est pas un hôpital
psychiatrique donc aujourd'hui oui
aujourd'hui plus qu'hier et puisque
demain le centre pénitentiaire de ducos
n'est pas adapté pour recevoir se
profile le détenu il soit d'autre donc
souhaitable pour la santé physique de ce
détenu pour la sécurité des personnels
que ceux détenus soient transférés dans
un établissement de métropole où il
pourra recevoir les soins adaptés
saisi de ce dossier très sensible il
semblerait que magistrat instructeur du
parquet de fort de france devrait se
prononcer très prochainement afin
d'éviter un nouveau drame en milieu
carcéral